die erzieherin sandra m soll die kleine
greta im april diesen jahres getötet
haben und zwar soll sie zu tode
gequetscht haben nun steht sie vor
gericht
das ist die mutmaßliche mörderin sandra
m 25 jahre jung die staatlich anerkannte
erzieherin soll die dreijährige greta in
viersen gequält und heimtückisch
ermordet haben auch schockierend sandra
m soll in anderen kitas bereits kinder
misshandelt haben die polizei und die
staatsanwaltschaft sind bei einer
pressekonferenz in mönchengladbach
extrem betroffen
100 rom ein solcher mensch dem
offenkundig sie dazu sagen sie kindern
fehlt wo man solcher menschlich einen
solchen beruf aus und bis dahin gekommen
ist beschreibung sind immer vergleichbar
keine empathie kein zugang zu kindern
und fehlende fähigkeit zu erkennen dann
muss ich als erzieherin dazwischen gehen
am tattag dem 21 april ist pippa wegen
der korona notbetreuung alleine in der
gruppe sandra m soll ihren mittagsschlaf
überwachen am frühen nachmittag dann
atemstillstand bei kreta kolleginnen
wählen den notruf versuche das kleinkind
zu animieren scheitern einen tag nach
ihrem dritten geburtstag stirbt greta
nierenschäden und durch massiven
sauerstoffmangel im krankenhaus an ihr
werden schwere gewalt spuren gefunden
wenn ein kind vorsätzlich getötet wird
davon gehen wir derzeit aus dem vortrag
deutlich geworden dann führten zu der
großen betroffenheit selbst bei
hartgesottenen ermittler
was das mit einer unterbrachten zunächst
davon ausgehen muss dass ihr kind an
einer krankhaften inneren ursachen
die dann durch uns erfahrung dass der
verdacht eines tötungsdeliktes jemand
untersuchungshaft geht mag sich jeder
hier vorstellen
sandra m sitzt weiterhin in u haft der
tatvorwurf heimtückischer mord und
misshandlung von schutzbefohlenen
das motiv ist völlig unklar allerdings
deute vieles auf eine psychische
erkrankung der erzieherinnen und sandra
m
sie schweigt mir nun zugeschaltet mein
kollege benjamin sagt benjamin
wie verlief der prozessauftakt war der
prozessauftakt war relativ schnell
vorbei hat gerade mal zwölf minuten
gedauert
es wurde nur die anklage verlesen die
angeklagte selber schaute dabei zu boden
hat das alles relativ gefasst
aufgenommen hat sich aber bisher noch
nicht zu großer das ist für den nächsten
prozesstag am donnerstag geplant da
möchte sandra m fragen zu ihrer person
beantworten und es soll eine erklärung
von ihren anwälten geben ob dann schon
das motiv eindeutiger wird ist fraglich
bisher schweigt sie dazu das ist absolut
rätselhaft was die junge frau dazu
bewogen hat drei kinder
in anderen kitas so dermaßen bis zum
atemstillstand dann zu quälen und dann
die rettungskette in gang zu setzen und
bei dem vierten kind kleingerät hat das
hat es nicht funktioniert wie es daran
gestorben
ja das ist gerade schon angesprochen die
anderen drei kinder es gab immer wieder
vorfälle in der vergangenheit und
trotzdem wurde sie immer wieder von
anderen kindergärten angestellt obwohl
sie die schlechte zeugnisse fahrzeuge
wird es doch irgendwelche konsequenzen
jetzt geben irgendwelche neuerungen
damit so etwas nicht noch einmal
passieren kann so eine frau nicht auf
kinder aufpassen kann und das wiederholt
in verschiedenen tagesstätten ja es gab
im sommer schon einer anhörung im
nrw-landtag david genau gefragt wie kann
das passieren
das halt solche notarzteinsätze in
kindertageseinrichtungen gibt und das
landesjugendamt als übergeordnete
behörde
davon nichts mitbekommt die
kindergartenträger die haben das alles
gemeldet haben ist der unfallkasse
gemeldet die haben es im jugendamt
gemeldet aber dann ist das einfach in
akten dann ja zum stillstand gekommen
niemand hat das an eine übergeordnete
behörde dann weitergeleitet deswegen
fiel auch nicht auf dass immer wenn ein
kind dann vom notarzt betreut wurde dass
da auch sandra m immer irgendwie da mit
involviert gewesen sein soll
der staatsanwalt stefan lingens hat
heute noch mal gesagt es wird auch
geprüft ob ein straff relevantes
verhalten bei den trägern zu finden ist
dem ist aber nicht so
also die vier kitas in den sandra heim
gearbeitet hat wo es diese vorfälle gab
die haben keine strafe zu befürchten
es gab bei der anhörung im sommer schon
deutlich gemacht dass das in zukunft
anders geregelt werden soll
wie das dann im einzelnen ablaufen soll
und ob dann einfach so ein tatgeschehen
in zukunft nicht mehr passieren wird ist
natürlich fraglich
es muss natürlich flächendeckend
irgendwie dann eingeführt werden die das
dann letztendlich dann genau umgesetzt
werden soll ob es da irgendwie in sachen
datenschutz dann noch irgendwelche neue
organisationen geben soll bei erzieherin
und trägern
das wird sich dann zeigen da gibt es
aktuell noch keinen neuen stand
wenn du sagst es ist fraglich auf jeden
fall ist sich glaube ich jeder mensch
eigentlich so was darf nicht noch einmal
passieren
du wirst den prozess rund um sandra m
weiter für uns begleiten vielen dank
benjamin sack für den moment wir sind
bild und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren